good morning Hank it's Thursday
September 11th and I can think of no
better day to think about ways we can
make the world suck less so here's a
video about videos video number one
Sean's collaboration would Save the
Children in Bangladesh Hank this video
is a video response to a video made by
Sean who as I'm sure you remember is a
nerdfighter who lives in Bangladesh and
works full-time to help decrease
worldsuck among the world's poorest kids
a few months ago a bunch of nerdfighters
came together to send Sean some money to
help people in Bangladesh he's already
used a lot of that money and made of
Awesome ways but now he wants to use the
rest of it working with Save the
Children to do something awesome but
here's the problem that Sean faces and
indeed the same problem that lots of
charities face when they're working in
the developing world there's just not
enough money to do everything that needs
to be done so you end up having to
choose do I do vitally important thing
eh or vitally important thing be what
matters most clean water the health of
infants education it's a very difficult
calculus so what Sean has done is he's
given us an introduction to a variety of
different things that we can do and this
time everybody has a voice in that
conversation we can go and vote on what
we think is the most important thing the
thing that should be done first with our
money and then Sean will do it now of
course I know a lot of you are saying
why don't we just send Sean more money
so he can do everything I'm all in favor
of sending Sean more money but that
still won't solve the problem I think
it's a profoundly difficult and complex
question and we shouldn't try to get out
of it just by sending more money instead
we should all have to make some of the
tough choices that Sean makes every day
video - Hank at the tail end of our
amazing night in Chicago with many many
nerdfighters on 8808 we met Amy Krauss
Rosenthal at the bean Amy Krauss
Rosenthal of course being the author of
many critically acclaimed in
best-selling books including
encyclopedia of an ordinary life and a
little pee in your pants what I love so
much about little pee in your pants is
that first you think god that would be a
disaster and then you think although if
I'm going to have an amount of pee in my
pants
other than none so we all went and met
Amy cross Rosenthal at the Bean hundreds
of us and we had no idea what she was
planning all we knew is that she had a
yellow umbrella well it turns out that
she was planning to make a movie and
that movie stars a ton of nerdfighters
including me and the movie she made is
only the first part of the project the
movie is called the beckoning of lovely
and now
lovely has been beckoned we can all go
make and do lovely things and send them
to Amy for her to make and do something
really lovely I'm very excited about
this it's the kind of thing that's right
up my alley more info about it in the
sidebar video 3 win fleet you know make
sometimes the world can seem like it's
not a very good place to be and like the
human experiment maybe isn't worth it
and gosh I wish that particle
accelerator would just create a black
hole and get it over with
but our biological impulses aside I
think there's something sort of
beautiful about bringing someone into
the world and promising to take care of
them and to make the earth as good a
place as you can for them our secret
siblings Debian's to have just done that
they made me a funny birthday video in
which they also introduce their new kid
Eli a link to that video is also in the
sidebar I thought it might be helpful if
we all went over and said hello Eli
welcome to the world we're gonna do
everything we can to make it suck as
little as possible for you videos 4 & 5
an extended question Tuesday I did with
Worthington libraries I guess it doesn't
really decrease worldsuck that much
except that libraries are awesome but I
did like 20 minutes worth of question
Tuesday with the Worthington libraries
the questions were awesome it has
everything that you'd ever want to know
about me and my books and more arguably
much more Hank Willy is winding behind
me which means I have to go take him out
I will make a video about the tour on
Saturday and I'll see you soon